here we are thank you good to see you
all right so you're safe with this first
question no spoilers involved so a good
chunk of this new season is focused on
daniel and johnny learning the
techniques of the other dojo so it feels
appropriate to ask you about that when
working with ralph what is something
that you've seen him do on set that you
have either applied to your own work as
an actor already or maybe you want to in
the future
oh that's a good question well uh i
don't know i think we just have such a
good chemistry i think i don't know we
just bounce off each other i mean
everything ralph does is great so uh i
don't know i'm not picking i think we by
osmosis we feed it off each other pick
up each other's techniques i think um
you know we work it so fast it's so hard
on these that it's about digesting the
lines and having them come right off and
you know he's always right there he's
always in the pocket so i try to do that
speaking of working really fast is there
any benefit for you in shooting seasons
four and five so close together yeah i
think it's good it was like a three
month break we had and then they called
us back so we were still coming off of
that you know it's good so i didn't get
my uh you know i kind of kept my shape
and and uh and then it's it just felt
like when we came back to do season five
it just felt like we just took a short
break which is what we did so yeah it
was definitely a benefit definitely in
the pocket and you still have the
residual kind of emotion of where you
left off
going through you don't have to reach
back a year and pull it out so
absolutely yeah it makes sense all right
this is where i'm going to put up the
spoiler warning so you can answer this
question freely but i was watching this
interview that you did with martin where
he was explaining that there was a scene
in season four that you guys were having
a tough time with so can you tell us
what that particular scene was and then
how the two of you kind of accessed it
yeah sure sure it's a scene at the in
the tournament and it's funny how we
were at comic-con and and marty you know
he pontificated about it made a little
bigger than it was you know we do we
gave notes all the time on scenes you
know so this is the scene at the uh at
the karate tournament where daniel and
cree i mean johnny and chris bump into
each other and have a moment and because
there's not so many of those moments for
us throughout the
the season
we just wanted it to be right for both
of us so we were playing we had so much
more we wanted to say to each other and
it was kind of our process as actors to
kind of get our subtext and to dig deep
and you know sometimes you rewrite
something or try to do something to to
to purge it and meanwhile you found
these
you found these new um
notes and thoughts and you're
communicating so it's all part of the
process the thing is it's in television
in this situation we're moving again so
fast that it hits we don't have months
to prepare for these scenes or weeks
even it's days and sometimes the night
before so in this case it was just a you
know it was a short notice and we you
know we were just trying to find if we
could massage it differently and it was
a great experiment and and and at the
end it really helped the scene though so
it's the cena hallway you'll see
if you haven't already
with that in mind is there any
particular scene in season four that
necessitated the most prep even though
you didn't have a lot of time something
you really wanted a workshop no matter
what
um yeah and now is this spoiler okay i
mean are we okay this is it yeah so i
mean the the the fight with daniel the
the you know squaring off again in the
backyard of miyagi dough
was super important for both of us to do
well physically and also emotionally and
for it to land right to have all the
balance in there so you know that was uh
you know i think episode 5 it's a
pinnacle point it's a turning point for
the characters it's where they're going
to separate um a lot of emotion in there
so uh that was that was that one we did
have time to prepare for there's a lot
of a lot of fighting in that and
you know and then at the end
a resolve you know
for better or worse at that moment
all right to wrap up here we do get a
tease of what daniel's plans are for
miyagido at the end of season four but
because johnny is primarily focused on
what happened with miguel we don't
really know what he's thinking about
eagle fang so can you kind of tease his
head space at the end of the tournament
is he going forward assuming that he
really will shut down eagle fang
well that's yet to be seen now they made
a bet with crease right i know here we
go you're fishing for five already i
love it
[Laughter]
you're good terry
turn me into a monster what's that you
guys turned me into a monster
with the show well as always it's um you
know the writers are gonna keep you on
your toes they do us um but they did
make a bet you know and we'll see what
we'll see what happens on that um you
know there's a is this spoiler okay
still like where people this moment know
what happened at the end
so you know at this point you know
daniel and johnny they separated but
then they come back together at the end
um but really
more than the martial arts more than the
me the eagle fang of it uh you know
they're connected to these people and
these humans these characters so johnny
starts with miguel wherever i'm gail is
and uh and robbie
um so what happens with the eagle fang
you know
we'll see
you're always so good with the teases
too far you're supposed to do that
really hard too because we're right in
the middle of shooting this stuff right
now so it all four and five are kind of
blurring together you know i can't
believe i'm dead writing all these
things for that reason
when we're allowed to talk about it you
will be the first person that i will uh
i'll give a spoiler to you you are the
best
congratulations on season four
genuinely loved it yet again thank you
so much have a good one thanks guys all
right